vamos a multiplicar 6 por 7 1981 y la
manera en que lo vamos a hacer es
representando este número 7 1981 como
siete mil siete mil más 900 más 900 más
80 más 80 más 1 más 1 y multiplicar 6
por 7 1981 es lo mismo que multiplicar 6
por 7 mil más 6 por 906 por 80 más 6 por
1 y lo que hacemos es distribuir el 6 y
para resolver esto vamos a poner el 6
aquí y tratar de pensar cuánto ve 6 por
7 mil cuánto es 6 por 946 por 86 por 1
estoy dibujando un rectángulo déjenme
dibujar este rectángulo
y ahora pensemos cuánto es seis por
siete mil seis por siete es 42 así que 6
por 7 mil es 42.000 cuánto es 6 por 900
bueno 6.9 54 entonces 6 por 906 5406 por
80 80 es ocho decenas o es 8 por 10
entonces 6 por 8 es 48 y como 80 es
igual a 8 decenas entonces seis por ocho
decenas es 48 decenas o 480 y finalmente
6 por 1 es igual a 6
entonces para obtener el resultado de
esta multiplicación tenemos que sumar
los números que tenemos aquí 6 por 7 mil
más 6 por 900 más 6 por 80 más 6 por 1 y
lo vamos a hacer aquí 42 mil
más 5400
6 y el resultado en la posición de las
unidades tenemos sólo el 6 en el lugar
de las escenas tenemos 8 en el lugar de
las centenas tenemos 44 es 8 y en el
lugar de los millares tenemos todos más
5 que es 7 y en el lugar de las decenas
de millar tenemos 4 y el resultado es 47
mil 886 esto es igual a 47 mil 886
y quisiera que pensarán que esto que
hicimos aquí no es muy diferente de las
técnicas tradicionales para multiplicar
esta es una manera muy útil de pensar en
la multiplicación porque podemos
entender realmente lo que está pasando y
pueden empezar a hacer esto en su mente
es lo que yo hago esta es la manera en
que resuelva problemas de multiplicación
miren si veo 6 por 7 en 1981 y no tengo
papel y lápiz entonces pienso cuánto es
6 por 7 mil es igual a 42 mil y trato de
recordarlo luego pienso cuánto es 6 por
900 es 5400 y lo suma a los 42 mil que
tenía antes y esto es igual a 47 mil 400
y luego 6 por 80 es igual a 480 y lo
sumo a los 47 mil 400 que estaba
recordando y eso es igual a 47 mil 880 y
luego cuánto es 6 por 1 eso es igual a 6
y lo sumo a los 47 mil
180 que tengo en mi mente y es igual a
47 1886
bueno esto les ayuda a entender qué es
lo que pasa cuando están haciendo una
multiplicación de varios dígitos y
también es una técnica muy útil para
hacer multiplicaciones mentales